- [Voiceover] We have a writing
and language passage here.
"Dong Kingman: Painter of Cities."
And what's neat about this
is as we go through it,
we'll have a chance to
think about how we might
edit this to make it maybe
a little more grammatically
correct or a little bit easier to read.
"A 1954 documentary about
renowned watercolor painter
"Dong Kingman shows the artist sitting
"on a stool on Mott Street
in New York City's Chinatown.
"A crowd of admiring spectators
watches as Kingman squeezes
"dollops of paint from several
tubes into a tin watercolor
"box, from just a few
primary colors, Kingman
"creates dozens of
beautiful hues as he layers
"the translucent paint onto
the paper on his easel."
So that sentence I just
read, that felt like a lot.
Even when I was reading it it
felt hard to put it, to get it
all out in one breath.
Where I paused here, at
least when I was reading it
it felt like that could
be a place where instead
of this being a comma and keep going.
This is a good place to
start a new sentence.
Let me just make sure that the two parts
of this long sentence right now
can stand as their own as sentences.
"A crowd of admiring
spectators watches as Kingman
"squeezes dollops of
paint from several tubes
"into a tin watercolor box."
Yeah, that's a sentence.
Then after that "From
just a few primary colors,
"Kingman creates dozens of
beautiful hues as he layers
"the translucent paint onto his easel."
Yeah. That's a sentence too.
So I for sure, would put
a period after box here.
And so when you see this
one, this means where,
this one with this gray box around it,
that means we're in question one.
Question one says do we want to rewrite
this underlined part, and if we do,
how would we do it?
So we go to this question
one right over here,
and I wanna change it.
I wanna put a period there
to make this one big sentence
into two cleaner sentences,
and out of these choices,
this is the only one that
puts the period after the box.
It makes it very clean,
just the way I said.
The period here and then
start a new sentence.
"From just a few primary colors."
This one over here actually
just removes the comma,
in some ways making those, what I think
should be two sentences even more run-on.
This one, they remove the comma back here,
but that doesn't help the situation.
I definitely don't wanna keep it as is,
so I feel very confident about B.
So let's keep going.
So I finished with easel.
"Each stroke of the brush
and dab of the sponge
"transforms thinly sketched outlines
"into buildings, shop
signs, and streetlamps.
"The street scene Kingman begins composing
"in this short film is
very much in keeping
"with the urban landscapes
for which he is known best."
Or "for which he is best known.
"Kingman," and when they have
these numbers in brackets,
this is now, they're just
numbering the sentences.
Some of these questions, they might refer
to these sentences in some way.
So the numbers in these gray boxes,
this is literally, "Hey,
how would you rewrite this
"underlined portion?" and
that's the question number.
While this is, they're
referencing the actual sentences,
so the first sentence
says, "Kingman was keenly
"interested in landscape
painting from an early age.
"In Hong Kong, where Kingman
completed his schooling,
"teachers at that time
customarily assigned students
"a formal 'school name.'"
Alright.
"His interest was so keen, in fact,
"that he was named after it."
That felt a little awkward.
He was named after what?
After his school?
Well anyway, I'll just keep reading.
"The young boy who had been called
"Dong Moy Shu became Dong Kingman.
"The name Kingman was
selected for its two parts,
"'king' and 'man'; Cantonese
"for 'scenery' and 'composition.'"
So this is question two,
how would we rewrite this?
And they're saying that the name
Kingman was selected for its two parts,
and then they give us a list of,
or they kind of give us
clarification of those two parts.
They say the two parts are king and man,
so instead of a comma here, I would
I'd probably go with a colon.
Hey I'm gonna enumerate the two parts.
I'm gonna say the two
parts, what were they?
They were king and man.
That's where a colon
would make a lot of sense.
And so let's see if the choices hopefully
have that as an option, and out of
all of these, it looks like
this one actually does.
It sees two "parts: 'king' and 'man,'"
and then they put a comma here
because then we clarify that king and man,
these are "Cantonese for
'scenery' and 'composition.'"
So this one feels very good.
I feel very confident about this one.
This one is even worse.
It kind of gets rid of that comma.
This one gets a semi-colon
right over here,
"two parts; 'king' and 'man.'"
Semi-colon's kind of too strong of a,
it's kind of making this a completely,
you know, we're kind of starting
another somewhat independent
clause over here, so I don't like that.
I definitely like putting the colon here
and then a comma here
because "Cantonese for
"'scenery' and
'composition,'" is giving us
more clarity where the king
and the man is coming from.
So I definitely like, but
what really convinces me is
putting the colon here
because it enumerates
the two parts, king and man.
"As Kingman developed
as a painter, his works
"were often compared to paintings
"by Chinese landscape artists dating back
"to the Common Era 960, a time
"when a strong tradition
of landscape painting
"emerged in Chinese art."
Actually, I, for question three, this
seems reasonable.
"As Kingman developed,"
I'm always suspicious of
myself when I do think that
something's okay, but
let me just double check.
"As Kingman developed
as a painter, his works
"were often compared to paintings by.
"His works were often
compared to paintings
"by Chinese landscape artists."
Yeah that's right. His works
would be compared to paintings
because his works are paintings.
"Landscape artists dating
back to CE 960, a time when
"a strong tradition of landscape painting
"emerged in Chinese art."
So for question three, I actually think,
I'm actually feeling no change,
but let's look at the other choices.
"As Kingman developed as a painter,
"his works were often compared to
"Chinese landscape artists."
No, you wouldn't compare his works,
which were paintings to other artists.
You might compare Kingman
to another artist,
but his works wouldn't be
compared to other artists.
You're comparing an object,
a painting, to people here,
so this doesn't make sense.
The next second one, "His
works were often compared
"to painters of Chinese landscapes."
Well, no that's the same thing.
You're comparing the works to people.
You might compare Kingman to painters,
but this is comparing "his works
"were often compared to,"
so it makes sense that his works would be
compared to paintings not
to "landscape artists"
or "painters of Chinese landscapes"
or compared to "artists," and it looks
like there's a little
typo right over here.
This D is probably, they
said "Hey this is D."
I'm using a prototype
version of the interface,
so there's probably gonna be a
little, few bugs on the stuff
that I'm making the videos on,
but this, you wouldn't want
to compare to the artists either.
So let's keep going, so
I feel good about the no change.
Alright, let's keep going.
So we are right,
we are right here.
"Kingman, however, vacated
from that tradition
"in a number of ways, most notably
"in that he chose to focus
not on natural landscapes,
"such as mountains and
rivers, but on cities."
So vacated seems like a bit
of an awkward word here.
I mean, to vacate means to leave,
so I guess, you know,
I kind of get what they're saying,
but it feels more like
left from that tradition
or departed from that tradition
might make more sense.
But let's see what the choices are,
so no change would be vacated,
then you have evacuated
from that tradition.
That kind of, at least in my brain,
I imagine like an emergency
where he has to leave the tradition.
Departed feels right.
He departed from that tradition.
He moved away from it in a number of ways.
Retired from that tradition?
Yeah, that also doesn't feel quite right.
So I would go with departed.
"Retired from that tradition
in a number of ways."
No, I think it's much more of,
I imagine like this splitting
off from that tradition.
"Kingman, however, split
from that tradition
"in a number of ways,"
would also be an interesting
way to say it, but they didn't
have that choice over here.
So let's keep reading.
So "Most notably that he chose to focus
"not on natural landscapes,
such as mountains
"and rivers, but on cities."
So now we have just
question five here, I guess,
is probably referring
to what we just read,
so let's see what question five is.
"For the sake of cohesion
of this paragraph,"
so that's the paragraph we just read.
This one right over here.
"For the sake of cohesion
of this paragraph,
"sentence 3 should be placed."
So sentence three is
this one right over here.
That's sentence three right over here.
Sentence here, and that's
actually the one that tripped me
up a little bit because I said,
"His interest was so keen,
"in fact, he was named after it."
And the sentence before they're talking
about students assigned
a formal school name,
so was he named after
his school in some way?
So A is leaving it where it is now,
B is before sentence one,
so that means that this would be
the first sentence of the paragraph.
"His interest was so keen, in fact, that
he was named after it. Kingman was keenly
"interested in landscape
painting from an early age."
No that doesn't.
This sentence is referring to something,
so something else has to be
written before.
This would not be something that you would
want to start the paragraph with.
Let's see, after sentence one,
so let's see how that would read.
"Kingman was keenly interested
in landscape painting
"from and early age.
"His interest was so keen, in fact,
"that he was named after it.
"In Hong Kong, where Kingman
completed his schooling,
"teachers at that time
customarily assigned
"students a formal 'school name.'
"The young boy who had been called
"Dong Moy Shu became Dong Kingman.
"The name Kingman was
selected for its two parts:
"'king' and 'man,' Cantonese
for scenery and composition."
Yeah, I actually like
this after sentence one
because now it actually,
that thing that tripped me up when I said,
"Hey if he was named after
it, he was named after what?"
But now it's clear he was
named after landscape painting.
"Kingman was keenly interested
"in landscape painting from an early age.
"His interest was so keen, in fact,
"that he was named after it."
He was named after landscape painting,
so it makes sense that sentence
three comes right after sentence one.
It's referring to what
happened in sentence one.
And we get, it clarifies later on
that he was named literally
after landscape painting.
"'King' and 'man', Cantonese for scenery
"and composition," landscape painting.
Now let's keep going,
so this says question
six of five, so I think
this is another bug
out of the early prototype
interface that I'm using,
but the important thing
is we do the questions.
So it says, "Which choice most,"
and so question six is referring I guess
to this entire paragraph.
"Which choice most effectively establishes
"the main topic of the paragraph?"
So let's read this paragraph.
"His fine brushwork conveys
detailed street-level
"activity: a peanut
vendor pushing his cart
"on the sidewalk, a
pigeon pecking for crumbs
"around a fire hydrant, an old man
"tending to a baby outside a doorway.
"His broader brushstrokes
and sponge-painted shapes
"created majestic city
skylines, with skyscrapers
"towering in the background,
bridges connecting
"neighborhoods on either side of a river,
"and enormous ships maneuvering
out of a busy harbor.
"To art critics and fans
alike, these city scenes
"represented the innovative spirit
"of twentieth-century urban Modernism."
Alright, it's talking
about all the different
ways that he's able to paint and really
convey what's happening in a city.
So "which choice most effectively
"establishes the main
topic of the paragraph?
"Kingman is considered a pioneer
of the California School of Style?"
Well no, they're not even talking
about the California Style.
I don't have to even finish
reading that first one.
"Although cities were his
main subject, Kingman did
"occasionally paint natural landscapes."
No this is really just talking
about all the different ways
that he really captured a city.
They didn't say that he, you know, also
occasionally did natural.
This is really about
how he captured cities.
"In his urban landscapes, Kingman captures
"the vibrancy of crowded cities."
Yeah, I think that's pretty much it.
That's what this paragraph is about.
"In 1929 Kingman moved to
Oakland, California, where he
"attended the Fox Art School."
No that is not what this
paragraph right here is about.
And so let's go to
question seven out of five.
So once again, I think this
should say seven out of seven,
but I think we get the point.
Let's answer this question.
"During his career, Kingman exhibited
"his work internationally. He garnered
"much acclaim. In 1936,
a critic described."
So that just felt a little
bit robotic when I read that.
"Kingman exhibited his work
internationally. Period.
"He garnered much acclaim.
"In 1936, a critic described
one of Kingman's solo exhibits
"as 'twenty of the
freshest, most satis--."
And I'm just reading this
just to finish the passage.
If you're running out of time on the SAT,
I would probably just try to answer
this question and move on.
But "'twenty of the freshest,
most satisfying watercolors
"'that have ever been seen
hereabouts in many a day.'
"Since Kingman's death
in 2000, museums across
"the United States and
in China have continued
"to ensure that his now-iconic landscapes
"remain available for
the public to enjoy."
Well let's go back to question seven.
So, let's see the choices.
So one is "internationally,
and Kingman also garnered."
So "Kingman exhibited his work
internationally, and Kingman
"also garnered much acclaim."
Now that just seems
a little wordy.
You're seeing Kingman
twice very close together.
You don't need to, so
I wouldn't do that one.
"Kingman exhibited his
work internationally;
"from exhibiting, he
garnered much acclaim."
So once again, this is kind of
you're using exhibited up here,
and you're using it again.
It feels redundant.
"Kingman exhibited his
work internationally,
"but garnered much acclaim."
Well but makes it seem
like garnering acclaim
is somehow something that you wouldn't
expect for someone who's
exhibiting internationally,
but they kind of go together.
You would, garnering acclaim
should go along with inter--
There shouldn't be a but there.
It shouldn't be kind of
contradicting it in some way
or going in another direction.
So this would be "Kingman exhibited
"his work internationally,
garnering much acclaim."
Yeah, just nice and simple.
Exhibiting his work
internationally, and in doing so,
he's garnering much acclaim.
Makes all the, feels nice and clean
and gets to the point
without being redundant
or in some ways
contradicting in a weird way.
Yeah, feel good about these answers.